Let's solve a few practical tasks,
related expressions containing
a variable.
And in these first tasks the goal is to record the following
in a more concise form, ignoring the multiplication symbol or
leave the multiplication symbol.
Here we have 2 times 11x, i. if we have 11 hyks, then
we will have 2 times those 11 chicks we will have
with 22 hyks.
Another way we can imagine this, 2 times at 11h, we can
to consider it as equal to 2 times by 11, and all that
is multiplied by x, and we will have a tie with the 22nd hyks.
We had 11 hyks, we would have twice as many hikes,
so we'll have 22 hiccups.
Let's see, we have 1.35, multiplied by y.
Now we will make a direct simplification here
of the record.
We have 1.35, multiplied by y-we will use a different color-1.35,
multiplied by y-here is a small point.
In the algebra, we can get rid of this little point.
If we have a variable after which a number comes, we know that
this means 1.35 times this variable.
So we can translate this as equal to 1.35u.
We have saved him from being overwhelmed by
the sign of multiplication.
Let's see, here we have 3 times 1/4.
And this is actually a direct multiplication with a liver.
And in Task 3 - this was Task 1, Task 2,
task 3- 3 times 1/4, this is exactly equal to 3
on 1, multiplied by 1/4.
By multiplying the numerators, we get 3.
By multiplying the denominators, 1, multiplied by 4, we denote 4.
And at number 3, I received 3/4.
Finally, we have 1/4, multiplied by z.
We can do the same thing we did here,
in Task 2.
That was exactly equal to 1.35e.
Same as 1.35e.
And here below we can translate this or as equals
1 / 4z, or we can treat it as 1 to 4 times
on z on 1, which is exactly equal to z times 1, on 4,
multiplied by 1, or is exactly equal to z on 4.
So all of these are tantamounts here.
So what do we have to do down here?
Calculate the following expressions, where a is equal
at 3, b is equal to 2, c is equal to 5, and d is equal
to minus 4- or, in fact, we have to say negative 4 is the right one
term.
Negative 4.
And we just replace it.
Every time we see one, we'll be minus 3 out there,
or a negative three.
Every time we see b, we will positively put 2.
Every time we see with, we will put 5.
And every time we see d, we will have 4.
Now I will solve a few of these.
We will not solve them all in order to save time.
Let us take example task 5.
Given is our example 2 times a plus 3 times b.
Well, this is exactly equal to 2 times-instead of,
we know that this will be equal to negative 3.
So, 2, multiplied by minus 3, plus 3 times b-what is b?
We have given that b is equal to 2, so we have 3 times 2.
And what is that equal?
2 times minus 3-let me use a different color-2 times
minus 3 gives minus 6, plus 3 times 2.
3 times 2 is 6.
This is a positive six.
And this is equal to 0.
Note the action line.
We did the multiples, we did the two multiples
before we add the two numbers.
Multiplication and division are performed before collection
and subtraction.
Let's solve task 6.
I'll write it here.
We have 4 times per village.
4 times-how much is equal to?
We have been given that is equal to 5.
Thus, 4 multiply by 5, this is ours, plus d.
d is minus 4 or negative 4.
So we have 4 times 5, which is 20 plus the 4th negative
the same as minus 4, so this is equal to 16.
Task 6.
Let's now solve a problem from the toughest down here.
This task 10 looks a bit more scary.
Task 10 here.
So we have a minus 4b in the numerator, I do not know if you see it,
it's kind of small.
but is minus 3.
Thus, we have a minus of 3 or negative three times minus four times b.
b is 2.
Ie. 4 times 2.
Remember this is here, and that's where b is.
How do I know it?
I'm told here above.
So, we have all this on all this
is on 3c plus 2d.
So, 3 times - what was it with? c is 5 plus 2, multiplied by d.
How much is d?
d e
minus 4.
And let's count here.
We must have a turn to act.
Multiplication is done first, before collection
and
subtraction.
This will be equal to minus 3 minus 4, multiplied by 2,
minus 8, all this on - 3 times 5 is 15, plus 2 times
by minus 4 is minus 8 or 15 plus negative
eight is 15 minus 8.
And now, the numerator becomes negative 3 minus 8, which is
negative 11.
And in the denominator we have 15 minus 8, which gives 7.
So in Task 10 we simplified to minus 11 on 7.
There it is visible.
Let's solve two of these tasks here.
Okay, we see some progressive indicators.
I will choose one of the more difficult tasks.
Let us solve this here, task 18.
We have 2x a square minus 3x per square, plus 5x minus 4.
So, well, it was not that difficult.
For all our tasks we have work with x.
But what we can do here - let's record.
2x per square minus 3x per square, plus 5x minus 4.
And we are told that x is equal to minus 1.
What we can do is simplify this expression before
to substitute with minus 1.
And how much does it give 2 by something minus 3 something?
How much does it give?
Here we have 2x of a square minus 3x per square.
And 2 by something minus 3 something, it will give
minus 1 on this thing.
So that there-or minus 1 on this thing-
this will give a minus 1x per square plus 5x minus 4.
We have been told that x is equal to minus 1.
So here we have minus 1, multiplied by x per square, negative 1 per square,
plus 5 times x which is minus 1, minus 4.
How much does it do?
Negative 1 per square gives 1.
Gives only 1.
And this whole expression is simplified to minus 1 plus
5 times minus 1-course,
we first perform the multiplication.
So here we have minus 5 or minus 5 minus 4.
Thus, minus 1 minus 5 gives minus 6, minus 4, equal
to minus 10.
And I'll decide these last two to have a model for everyone
types of tasks in this kind of expressions for variables.
The weekly price, with, the produced x distance
Controls-the price is with, x is the number of remote controls-this
is given by this formula.
The price is equal to 2000 plus 3 times the number
of remote controls, where the price is in dollars.
Question a, what is the cost of production?
of 1000 remote controls?
Well, the cost of the remote controls is x.
So for part a-I can write it here-the price
will be equal to-just use this formula-2000 plus
3 times the number of remote controls.
x is the number of remote controls.
So, 3 times 1000.
And this will be equal to 2000 plus, 3 times 1000
is 3000, all this gives $ 5,000.
So, that's part, $ 5000.
Now part b.
What is the cost of producing 2000 remotes?
Well, the price-I use the same formula-is equal
of 2000 plus 3 times the number of remote controls.
So, we have 3 times in 2000.
And this is equal to 2000 plus 3 times in 2000, which is 6000.
All this amounts to $ 8,000.
We are now in charge of 22.
The volume of a box without a lid is given by the formula,
the volume is equal to 4x, multiplied by 10 minus x per square, where x expresses
length in inches, and v - volume in cubic inches.
What is the volume when x is equal to 2?
Thus, part a, x is equal to 2.
We just substitute with 2 everywhere where we see x.
The volume will be equal to 4 times x, x is
2, multiplied by 10 minus 2 per square.
And this will be equal to: 4 times 2 is 8, multiplied
at, 10 minus 2 is 8, square.
So, we have 8 times-this is equal to 8 times-
8 per square is 64.
We can say that this will be 8 at third degree.
And 64, multiplied by 8-4, multiplied by 8 is 32.
6, multiplied by 8 is 48, plus 3 gives 51.
So we got 512.
So, what is the volume at x equal to 3?
I will calculate it here in pink color. b, when equal to 3, then
the volume is equal to 4 times 3 - now x is equal to 3 times multiplied by 10
minus 3 per square.
4 times 3 is 12, multiplied by 10 minus 3 is 7 per square.
This is equal to 12, multiplied by 49.
And to get the right answer, let's multiply that.
Thus, 49 times 12-2 times 9 is 18, 2 times 4
is 8, plus 1 gives 9.
We put 0.
1, multiplied by 9 is 9.
1, multiplied by 4 is 4.
And then we add both.
We obtain 8, 9 plus 9 is 18,
and then we have 1 plus 4, this makes a total of 588.